[Música]
eu trabalho na área de educação musical
e com música sacra e alguém me disse uma
vez música talvez seja a arte mais
praticada
porém a menos refletida muitos aqui eu
sei que gosta de ouvir música
muitos aqui gostam de cantar talvez
tocar um instrumento musical
mas muitas vezes nós não refletimos
sobre a linguagem musical da maneira
correta ea nossa é a nossa pequena
palestra desta tarde fala sobre a
concepção de deus e um estilo de música
sacra ao longo da história
no contexto cristão a música praticada
nas comunidades nas igrejas foi mudando
o seu estilo gradualmente isso muitas
vezes gerou conflitos debates discussões
agora se nós olharmos para a música não
ocidental a música não cristã por
exemplo a música praticada na áfrica
central nos rituais xamânicos das
religiões afro é interessante que parece
que esse tipo de música não sofreu
modificações ao longo da história
eles entendem por exemplo que se eles
mudarem instrumentação mudar o estilo
musical talvez as entidades os espíritos
que se manifestam não se manifestem
então a música oriental ou no geral não
se modificou por exemplo os monges
tibetanos se você visitar o mosteiro vai
perceber que eles cantam mesmo estilo
musical há séculos
já no contexto ocidental no contexto do
cristianismo quando falou que seria uma
maneira muito ampla não focando em
nenhum movimento religioso no contexto
cristão a música foi se transformando
isso se deu por vários fatores de um
desses fatores tem a ver com a visão que
as pessoas tinham de deus
a visão a maneira como elas viam a
divindade
se nós iniciamos a nossa breve viagem
pela história da música
nós começamos no período medieval foram
mais ou menos mil
anos no qual dos quais a igreja as
pessoas têm uma visão de um deus muito
distante a visão podemos chamar de deus
além de nós as pessoas na idade média
entendiam que deus era alguém ser
arbitrário um ser que julgava que punirá
o povo é a distância do homem para deus
era muito grande e isso refletirá em
toda a arte medieval não só na arte
sacra mas o contexto musical medieval
nós temos o principal exemplo que é o
conhecido cantor chão também chamado
canto gregoriano o cantochão era um
canto praticado nas igrejas do período
medieval
ele tinha algumas características por
exemplo
nesse período apenas os homens poderiam
participar dos momentos de adoração nas
igrejas cristãs apenas o clero poderia
participar as pessoas o povo à
congregação não tinha espaço dessa
liturgia era uma liturgia na verdade
contemplativa as pessoas viam para a
igreja pra contemplar algo então vocês
imaginem aquele canto de homens na
igreja e soando na acústica daquelas
igrejas cristãs grandes aquele vitral ao
fundo as pessoas tinham um vislumbre do
céu um deus muito distante de deus além
de nós esse coro é formado pelos pelos
monges pelo clero ele cantava músicas na
língua latina então a maioria das
pessoas não entendia o que estava a
letra o texto que está sendo cantado
geralmente esse texto era extraído das
escrituras dos livros dos textos da
bíblia e esse era o contexto medieval
outra característica medieval os
instrumentos musicais fabricados
construídos pelos homens não adentrava a
igreja o cantochão era um canto à capela
a concepção então medieval deus além de
nós um deus distante ea música dessa
época era mais ou menos assim você pode
ouvir
o canto à capela
hoje o nosso lixo do chão g20 e por ser
um canto plano um ano sem tantos sem
tensões
as pessoas vinham para a igreja e queria
alcançar e lhes comprar o céu deus além
de nós
o tempo passa depois de mais ou menos
mil anos chegamos do período da reforma
protestante
alguns dias atrás celebramos os 500 anos
da reforma e uma nova compreensão da
doutrina da salvação foi apresentada por
martinho lutero e isso influenciou toda
a arte e na cientista e arte barroca e
essa influência chegou na música sacra e
algumas algumas novidades que
aconteceram que apareceram nesse momento
os instrumentos musicais que antes
estavam na mão dos trovadores estavam
fora da igreja os instrumentos musicais
agora adentram a igreja as músicas
a liturgia as homilias as pregações
agora eram feitas no vernáculo ou seja
as pessoas simples podiam entender o que
está sendo cantado e que estava sendo
pregado uma liturgia muito mais próxima
e essa visão não é mais deus além de nós
mas sim a deus por nós
a visão desse período da reforma
protestante em diante é interessante que
eles pegavam estruturas da música
popular da música que o povo gostava que
o povo cantava fora da igreja e
trouxeram para a igreja ou seja o culto
agora era algo agradável
as pessoas têm um prazer em assistir às
celebrações religiosas e um grande
compositor que trabalhou para a igreja a
igreja reformista e luterana foi o run
sebastian bar conhecido mestre grande
mestre da história da música um
compostor luterano que tinha um cargo de
mestre de capela ele era nada mais nada
menos que um diretor de música das
igrejas numa determinada comunidade da
alemanha e ele a cada semana compunha
uma nova peça sacra
para coro e para orquestra é
interessante que nesse período deus por
nós estamos um segundo momento a
preocupação estética é importante na
idade média de ti nenhuma preocupação
com a questão estética mas nesse período
deus por nós
a preocupação com a beleza a beleza
artística adn entra os tempos os templos
cristãos deus por nós
o tempo passa esse período anterior ele
corresponde ao período do renascimento
na história da arte e ao período barroco
a nossa viagem continua
chegamos agora deus ao nosso lado nos
séculos 17 e século 18
as pessoas começaram a entender o poder
da música para ser usada no evangelismo
a música agora tinha uma dimensão
espiritual
a música era usada na como catalisador
da experiência espiritual do cristão a
experiência do crente a música agora
tinha uma carga mais emocional
nessa época ocorreram várias grandes
cruzadas evangelísticas na inglaterra
na américa do norte e as pessoas agora
aqueles grandes movimentos pietismo
grandes reavivamento sas pessoas usavam
a música para tocar o coração das
pessoas
é uma dimensão mais imanente da música
deus está ao nosso lado e essas
transformações
e essa mudança de pensamento essa
mudança da concepção do divino ela
também influencia e influenciou a música
a música nas igrejas vamos ver agora o
exemplo número 3 que isso tem a ver com
esse período deus ao nosso lado
[Música]
você tem uma igreja agora a entrada do
canto lírico o canto lírico a dentro da
igreja enquanto na idade média
não existe o conceito de harmonia era
apenas uma só voz
agora nós temos o que a ponte foi lia
duas ou mais vozes
era uma grande orquestra deus ao nosso
lado você vê como a linguagem musical
foi se transformando ao longo da
história e como eu disse muitas vezes
essas mudanças geravam conflitos
aquelas pessoas que aceitavam os novos
estilos e as pessoas que rejeitava os
novos elementos que adentravam a igreja
a nossa viagem continua saindo dos
séculos 17 18 iniciamos a parte final do
século 19 nós temos agora deus dentro de
nós
primeiro deus além de nós
depois de deus por nós no contexto da
reforma
em seguida deus ao nosso lado ea partir
do século 19 até os nossos dias
desde agora está dentro de nós e esse
movimento influenciou o movimento
pentecostal que hoje nós conhecemos
pentecostal neopentecostal e como é que
um estilo de música dessa concepção do
divino deus dentro de nós é um tipo de
música que mais uma vez apela às emoções
a liturgia deste momento é uma liturgia
também que muitos e é muito sensorial as
pessoas vão para o ambiente da igreja
para sentirem bem
elas vão para a igreja elas choram elas
se emocionam
elas querem se sentir bem uma um tipo de
concepção que apela bastante aos
sentidos e isso tem muito a ver com a
música quando você fala de música desse
período
existe uma grande exploração do elemento
da repetição percebe aquelas moças se
repetem a mesma idéia é repetir durante
quatro cinco seis oito minutos é um tipo
de música que muito repetitiva que
aborda temas existencialistas temas
relacionados também a auto ajuda a deus
agora não é um deus distante mas deus
está dentro de mim isso como eu disse
trouxe deu origem ao movimento
pentecostal é um tipo de música muito
também subordinada aos 6
os mediáticos a música está presente nos
meios de comunicação
a música também tem interesses
comerciais interesses comerciais muito
grandes estão por trás dessa concepção e
nós temos um exemplo de música exemplo
número 4 de música desse período você
conhece bem esse estilo de risco
olha
e agora
[Música]
ele é gaúcho
elementos da música popular também
adentro em 75 estão
[Música]
é isso quem é quem no brasil o uso que
se leve em conta a experiência do frente
com a atividade
você percebe a diferença como a música
sacra ocidental foi se transformando a
diferença de estilos de instrumentos de
estruturas musicais
agora essas reflexões são importantes
nós precisamos utilizar a música de
maneira inteligente precisamos ter noção
critérios na escolha do repertório a
música é muito importante na educação
das crianças na formação de jovens de
que adolescentes e também na no contexto
da duração que você possamos compreender
as modificações
as transformações que a linguagem
musical sofreu ao longo da história e
possamos utilizar critérios adequados
para usar a linguagem musical da melhor
maneira possível
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]